if you didn't already associate Hideo  Kojima's work with PlayStation you will  now an unconfirmed report says the first  game from his new studio may debut on  Sony platforms kept you waiting out  today December 15th marks Kojima's final  day at Konami but he swarmed a new  studio with some of his old team from  Kojima Productions the scope of his  talks with other platform holders is  unclear but Japanese website Nikkei says  his new venture is definitely partnered  with Sony Konami still has the rights to  Metal Gear so this will be a totally  original game it was sad knowing  kojima's final days of konami were  coming and even worse when he was warned  not to attend the game awards but now  everything seems to be coming up kajima  we're excited to hear about the new  studio and whatever games they plan to  develop stay tuned to gamespot as the  story develops